Let's go to our caller from the five seven
zero area code.
Who's calling today from five, seven zero.
Hi David, this is Hector.
Hector.
Oh, great.
Um, so I w I have two questions to ask you.
Um, so the, the first one is the most, um,
like, um, how do you want to say, like the
most serious question, which is like, Oh,
not a question, but more like a comment actually.
Um, like, you know how you were saying I'm,
I'm Hispanic and, uh, uh, you are Hispanic
as well and you know how you were saying like,
you don't consider yourself to be necessarily,
um, of color.
Right?
Um, well, my skin is very, it's fairly, um,
light.
So I'm from the Dominican Republic and a lot
of Dominican Dominicans are, are darker.
Yup.
Um, out of my work, uh, I have, uh, um, uh,
well not necessarily like I'm manager, but
he's like higher up on me and he's just wasn't
making more messed up jokes in the workplace
about Dominicans.
Um, and I live in the Northeast Pennsylvania,
uh, area and he's from Hazleton.
And, uh, it was just like super annoying and
I basically took him to the side and I was
like, dude, what are you doing?
This is so annoying and you have no idea how
stupid you sound.
Yup.
You feel like there's a lot of my to grow
up from this.
People around here like that are, um, you
know, just when they're in their ways, you
know.
Um, I dunno.
But, um, the other question or my, my actual
question is, uh, what are your favorite Argentinian
rod pants?
Uh, okay.
So, so I want to get back to that first thing
cause it's interesting, but some Argentinian
bands I like include, um, Fabulosos Cadillacs.
Autentico [inaudible] um, petticoats I saw
that's reggae, saw them here in Boston actually.
Uh, [inaudible] is a great band.
Um, there's just so many, there's so many
great Argentinian rock bands.
But, so what, what was your coworkers reaction
when you said, Hey, you know, I, I don't like,
I don't like those comments that you're making.
So my coworkers reaction was, um, like, uh,
dude, uh, I understand, I apologize and only
start stuff.
And he did apologize.
But you know, I just feel like, um, it's an
a very fake plane that he did that.
Right.
Well, it's not like you saying something is
going to change.
This person's deeply held beliefs.
Right.
It might make them moderate what they say
in public, but it's not like saying one thing
will actually get them to reconsider their
views more than likely.
Yeah, absolutely.
I agree 100%.
Yeah.
I just like I w I wish there was a better
way for me.
It makes sense.
We are such a small company.
We don't have an HR and I wish that we, there
was a better way of me being able to deal
with this.
Right.
Um, but I dunno.
Uh, yeah I just wanted to like break out,
you know, first time calling or doing something
ever like this.
So.
Yeah.
All right Hector, very good.
Appreciate you sharing the story.
It sounds horrible.
I've had similar situations myself and that
it is, it is very, very ugly.
I hope to hear from you again.
Thank you so much for the call.